the ticktock ification of social media
over the next 5 years is going to change
the world it could start tomorrow and
unlike social for the last decade where
it would have to do a lot of work to
amass followers who then would see the
content if it just leans into contextual
creative not just the formats but the
psychology of why someone is in their
stream on YouTube versus on LinkedIn
versus Tik Tok and was great at that
creative with the purpose of relevance
and consideration but also extracting
consumer insights that it would be able
to have virality from day one reach and
it would be based on Creative that
actually was relevant to the
segmentation we were looking for which
leads to consideration and if we were
thoughtful about how we wrote The Copy
we would extract real consumer insights
that's where marketing is going